the jurogan experience we were just
talking about
uh hagler before um the the uh podcast
started
and how crazy it is that he's gone it's
i i just can't believe it it's just i
believe that guy
like he was so he was so disciplined
when i was a kid i remember you know i
talked about it in this instagram post
that i made
they had some um some profile of him
when he was prepared i think he was
preparing for a mustafa ham show
and he was running on the beach and it
was that's what i wanted to ask you
about
i've been watching you and tyson was on
the podcast right he's like he's running
into the snow screaming wow
yeah and i was trying to find it all
week for following [ __ ] man i wish i
could find it
some local news shows like i was i was
probably like 15.
yeah and i remember just watching it
going
because he was starting and he was doing
sit-ups and push-ups and you know he was
just so
disciplined nobody was more conditioned
than hagler
nobody like he was just when he fought
mugabe
he just just kept the heat on him just
kept the heat on him
[ __ ] that fight was crazy mugabe was
putting people to sleep
i remember i was working at this boxing
gym and they were talking about mugabe
like long before he fought hagler
but he fought this dude and gained brain
damage he like he knocked him out he's
like the guy was never the same again
it's like there's
certain guys that just have punching
power that's just out of this world
and mugabe was one of them remember
julian jackson um
no i don't think the [ __ ] julian jackson
was another one he had this
they called him the hawk he had this
crazy punching power
i mean he looked he looked like a solid
guy but for whatever reason
when that guy would touch people they
would just stiffen up uh
julian jackson is like one of the most
ferocious power punchers ever in the
history of boxing yeah i love hacking
i'm watching him all week which is weird
right because i've watched haggler for
like
about a year two years i haven't watched
him but for some reason
um i just felt that energy last week on
fight week
so from sunday to um when i got to got
to vegas i was just watching and
watching him watching him
um i was posting my instagram even
posted on my instagram
um all week i was posting him and then
um
just before i left um to go to the apex
i was watching his fights and i went to
my room to
have a little on rest then i got a
message that i
agreed i was like i just posted him like
an hour ago
is that that's [ __ ] crazy crazy yeah
well like i said
he's disciplining the way the way he
worked and
that's inspiration um inspiration to me
you know and
i watched his documentary that first 30
fights
i didn't get paid no more than like i
said like 12 000
or something because there was no like
no one nobody wants to fight him you
know and
just i took inspiration from that you
know what else i love
he got out on top he's like i'm done try
to get a rematch of sugary leonard sugar
leonard said no one that fights yeah
i thought he won when i watched it it
was a split decision right i think it
was
and so he just said good i'm done that's
it out on top and
the rest of his life spoke well catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience